ciao io sono giulio vita sono un
italiano cresciuto in venezuela scusate
il mio tognolo nell'anno 2007 studiavo
giornalismo a caracas
durante una manifestazione contro il
governo sono stato arrestato dalla
polizia e torturato dai militari
accusato di guarin ba ri governo nel suo
l'anno significa guarin ba e fare casino
però per gli indios venezolani guarin ma
significa a posto sicuro
due anni dopo questa esperienza sono
stato vittima di un sequestro poco dopo
ho deciso che era il momento di tornare
in italia
così allora però qui ho deciso di
andarmene a madrid a studiare cinema lì
ho conosciuto sarà la mia compagna che
studiava belle arti era un'illustratrice
dopo che ci siamo laureati ci siamo resi
conto che quelli che studiano arte non
hanno un lavoro almeno in arte allora
abbiamo deciso di ho deciso di tornare
alle mie radici e di tornare nell'unico
posto dove tutto è possibile
in calabria allora miss allora mi sono
spostato con la mia ragazza in calabria
per fare un festival di cinema
indipendente è basato sulla meritocrazia
non di tappeti rossi ma tappeti verdi e
siamo andati in là e abbiamo scoperto un
cinema all'aperto abbandonato di 938
posti e ci siamo messi a ripararlo
abbiamo parlato col proprietario el
abbiamo iniziato a riparare la prima
inizio venne ha portato più di mille
persone ogni sera io durante questo
processo imparato un bel po di cose e
oggi voglio condividere con voi
quest'anno sarà la terza edizione della
gua rimba e vabbè cosa imparato diciamo
ok investi nei tuoi sogni tempo e denaro
appena siamo arrivati lì abbiamo preso
tutti i nostri risparmi che erano scarsi
eravamo artisti e ce li abbiamo messi
per fare il festival e abbiamo lavorato
18 ore al giorno per fare questa cosa se
non gravi turno i tuoi progetti chi lo
farà la seconda rispetto ai tuoi valori
con una foto che ho preso prima che
riprendessero grazie quest'anno
porteremo per la prima volta in italia
vimeo il più grande e la più grande
piattaforma video e tutti mi hanno detto
ma perché non lo portate a roma oa
milano tanto troverete più sponsor no
perché in calabria
chi vuole investire per o no la cosa
bella è la vera innovazione è portare il
futuro lì dove ancora si vive in passato
dopo ok creare una rete di persone che
condivida le tue motivazione è molto
importante la rete io oggi sono qui
grazie una rete di persone che credono
in questo progetto abbiamo persone
infiltrate in redazioni di giornali e
amministrazioni culturali allora quello
ci fa abbiamo fatto un tour l'anno
scorso in america se ne siamo andati un
tour in spagna
siamo stati in egitto tutto grazie a
tutte queste persone che credono in
questo progetto allora non abbiate paura
di chiedere ho bisogno di aiuto aiutami
il mondo è pieno di sognatori come ben
stupidi
ci sono ancora più di più gente che
vogliono evitare questi sognatori e sono
necessari sono la benzina di questo
sogno
immagina il tuo progetto da adesso a 10
anni
non c'è un giorno della mia vita che io
non mi sveglio immagino il catalogo
della guarin ba del decennale che sarà
una figata
io lavoro ogni anno per quel catalogo
tutto si trasforma hai la capacita di
attirare forse positive questa è la
parte new age di tutto del talk beh ha
infine hanno suonato i pink floyd con
tutta la sigo delia posso permettermi
allora è l'importante è questo essere
onesto con se stessi essere onesti con
il tuo progetto
non so spiegartelo perché sono ateo però
creato un po in queste cose allora sì
onesto qualcosa di buono succederà
ci teniamo a dirvelo tutto è
migliorabile
ci sono due tipi di arroganza in
calabria abbiamo l'arroganza brutta
crediamo che siamo i migliori in tutto
perché un polo siamo la seconda invece è
l'arroganza buona che dice io posso
essere il migliore e devo dimostrarlo
ogni giorno ma non a voi a me stesso
devo dimostrarlo
allora facendo così credendo che tutto è
migliorabile sempre sarà in concorrenza
con te stesso allora sarà imbattibile
mica cazzi
ascolta tutti anche chi non rispetti
soprattutto quando sei in una piccola
realtà con un'idea incredibile hai
bisogno di che questa idea abbia un buon
contenuto una buona forma per inviare
questo messaggio soprattutto scorda
imbecilli non perché devi cambiare il
contenuto il tuo messaggio ma la forma
in cui lo dai spam
parla con tutti sempre del tuo progetto
non sai chi ti sta ascoltando fatti o
spammato riccardo e mi ha invitato qua
l'ultimo il mio consiglio per voi questa
sera è la cosa più importante che ho
imparato fallisci non c'è un'altra
strada per il successo
ok siamo siamo troppo abituati
nell'educazione occidentale tranne
montessori quella santa però
l'educazione occidentale ci insegna che
fallire è una cosa sbagliata che quello
è fallito allora non vale invece no
ragazzi avere successo molto pericoloso
a me piace pensare che la guarin ba è
una serie di fallimenti che ogni tanto
capita che sono un successo
ok abbiate ovviamente imparate non fate
fallite falli della stessa cosa no vabbè
avete capito
per ultimo voglio dirvi una cosa
veramente vi ho mentito lavori ma non è
un festival di cinema lavori ma un atto
di resistenza perché riportare il cinema
alla gente l'azienda al cinema ogni anno
per noi è la cosa più importante che
possa esistere perché crediamo nella
cultura come un dovere come un diritto
noi dal secondo anno non abbiamo più il
cinema che abbiamo riparato e per noi è
stato un po un fallimento perché non ce
l'hanno pestato più rabbia momento
cavoli che facciamo però abbiamo
inventato tutto abbiamo preso un parco
pubblico
abbiamo chiamato airstream il più grande
distributore di schermi gonfiabili e
abbiamo creato un cinema là dove non
c'era e questo terzo anno continueremo
in quel parco e questo per dirvi che
veramente uno può fare tutto non deve
scusarsi di che non non ho le risorse
non ho il tempo non è vero non è vero
tutti possiamo fare tutto e io finisco
qui grazie a tutti